yeah let's not talk about optic okay
that's secretly what it is so here he is
again it's Matt gaunt thanks everyone so
this talk is going to be about cross
device development like Jake said if my
clicker would work my name is Matthew
gone I have this wonderful photo thanks
to addy Osmani he took the photo he then
decided I know what I want to exercise
my photoshop skills and make him like
Popeye so thank you mr. Osmani you could
argue that they shouldn't really be a
need for this kind of talk in the sense
that one of the beauties of the web is
the fact that if you've got a browser it
does mean that you can sit there and
develop for it but the biggest issue
with mobile devices you can imagine a
scenario like this this poor guys in
there thinking I'm going to develop for
all those and it's going to be great by
his face maybe not so much and I think
the main reason that it kind of becomes
a bit difficult is you you have this
environment on your desktop we're
developing what is the road to go from
your desktop to supporting all these
devices what are going to be the
obstacles how do you get around them
what how do you essentially smooth out
that path and we've all seen that whole
dragging backwards or forwards a window
and I think generally people will fall
into two camps pretty quickly like they
think no that's not mobile development
that's awful how could you claim that
the other side to be like well it's not
that bad it kind of it just helps you
get there my kind of opinion is it helps
you focus on the content rather than
necessarily devices which is the right
way of doing things in my opinion but at
the same time you can imagine a scenario
like this where if you take a nexus 4
you put it in landscape is sort of the
same size as a nexus 7 in portrait and
realistically I don't want to give users
the same experience on both those
scenarios based off a width and then you
can start obviously doing media queries
with orientation but unless you actually
sit there with a device in your hand
playing around
it the incentive to go and do that extra
work may not be apparent so we get to
this point where we say whoa ok I need
to support these devices and this kind
of looks like a nice structured way of
having all your device in a nice
beautiful wall but it's still daunting
as to how you can actually utilize this
and develop arm in the same way so for
me I kind of I still break things down
into three buckets for how I like to
approach these kind of things number one
is this the iteration speed when i'm
developing i want to be able to get a
fast turnaround over what I'm doing
second one is launching and that kind of
sounds a bit insane the fact that I'm
going to tell you how to launch a
browser like tap that little icon but
I'm going to and then there's emulations
as mr. Poulos has shown you there's
already one tool so iterations for me
one of the main reasons people like
tools like live reload to the fact they
don't have to hit this icon and it's
kind of insane to say but there are
still people who are constantly just
hitting refresh I watched one guy who
had made a change in his text editor
went to Chrome he hit a plug-in that
would clear the cache then hit the
refresh button he was doing that for
each change looks like what are you
doing just open devtools it clicks the
cash and then use live reload and you
don't touch anything and for me I grant
for a build tool but one of the nice
things is you get a load of these extra
modules for free and one of those that
literally rely on is library load so if
you're not familiar with grunt I think
about that was like half that maybe used
it it's essentially a way of pulling in
third-party modules and tasks that would
essentially perform some action for you
so the main one for live reload is this
watch task right here and basically what
this is doing is saying whenever a file
changed in my file system I want you to
perform certain tasks so here we've got
our compass task and whenever a sass
file
oil changes I want you to run the
compass server and then run this auto
prefix a task now I loved flexbox when
it first started coming out and I was
playing with it the thing I hated was
the fact that I had multiple versions
with multiple vendor prefixes that I had
to deal with auto prefix I just took all
of that away and I've literally never
looked back so once we've got these
other tasks that have run through and
changed whatever we need we have this
library load task now what live reload
will do is it will inject a script into
my HTML and then basically it will start
running the library load server in the
back end as well so what that means is
whenever I make a change it'll tell the
browser to update so that's definitely
not what I want there we go so what that
means is as soon as I come into here I
can start making my page look beautiful
yeah there we go and obviously like I
said it's not just necessarily sass and
everything else it will start changing
files when it comes to JavaScript as
well and this is great because it's not
just something that you have in desktop
this applies to mobile as well but you
could be quite fooled into thinking well
that all sounds good and great but that
grunt file and all the stuff that you've
done is kind of horrible and I'd
completely agree with you if I were to
write that I would fail miserably and
probably spend several hours crying
making every single task play nice and
it's at that point you can use something
like human if you haven't who's heard of
human before okay look good for those
who haven't human is essentially a tool
that helps you scaffold out a new
project it kind of gives you a good set
of defaults and it can also ask you a
set of things you might want to add in
that is kind of specific to you personal
taste the main reason I like human is
because it can kind of touch on the
whole lifecycle of your app it doesn't
necessarily just have to be billed or
Pacific tools that you like it can
actually touch on a number of things and
when we were first talking about human
and web development and whether it
should be mobile first anything else we
SAT and said well do people want a load
of tools specific to mobile and if we do
what are those tools going to be so me
and addy we kind of come up this notion
of well what I really want to do is
basically have a mobile builder and find
out what tools people actually want to
use so we came up with the mobile
generator so the way you work with human
if you say yo and then the project you
want to scaffold out so in this case
mobile yeah there we go brief moment of
fear where I thought demo was going to
fail so the kind of things this gives
you is it will give you first a choice
of whichever framework you want to build
with so whether that's bootstrap pure
CSS topcoat foundation it'll then I'll
see whether you want to include any
boiler boiler plate from that framework
similar bootstrap it comes
that kind of canonical responsive design
it'll also add in a task that could do
the source set for you so it or resize
the images create the source if you've
ever come across fast clip from ft labs
it's designed to remove a 300
millisecond delay in some of the
browsers although that's going away
pretty fast with firefox and chrome at
least it can also add in a task for
phantom jess and casper guess which is
it's a way of essentially taking your
web page start server and then basically
change the view port for you and then
create a set of images so that way you
kind of get a really quick turnaround as
to what your site looks like across
various devices well do port sizes
browser stack testing the idea with this
is you could just go grunt open Nexus 5
and then it would just go to browser
stack in a new tab and open up a nexus 5
emulator for you or whatever it might be
quiet air support converting images to
web p polyfill for acing local storage
also some boilerplate for full screen
api is kind of interesting seeing what
people are trying to do around this
because you need user interaction if you
can kind of get these to scroll and then
as soon as they start scrolling off the
URL bar then kick in full screen api
this just simplifies it for you and the
last thing we offered developers was if
you're using moderniser to basically
help you with feature detection it's
kind of nice and development of stage
just to have all the tests you could
want but the same time good practices
you sit there and pick the test you
actually need and clear out afterwards
and there's a task exactly for that i'm
not going to build it because it takes
whatever with NPM but the point of this
is the fact that with you and it kind of
exposes you to a new kind of workflow in
the sense of there's a load of tools out
there that you can use and just
basically get at your fingertips why
haven't you gone full screen there we go
so if you haven't checked it out it's
well worth just playing around with it
you can get it from NPM and it has a
load of good features now library load
isn't just grunt there are a number of
other tools how they do it one of them
is ghost lab now ghost lab has this
really nice other feature which I'm
going to give you a quick demo of there
we go so one of the nice features with
ghost lab is you can drag a directory it
creates a server for you and it will do
the library loading but one of the other
cool features if I launched the just a
demo page was just a plain HTML spot I
have this on my tablet yes
let's move out of the way all right so
you can sorta see tablet there now one
of the nice things here is it starts
sinking up what I'm doing are my desktop
with what's going on on the tablet now
you can imagine a really nice to know or
if you're testing across multiple
devices and you want to see what the
entire UI all of those devices looks
like you can just do it from your your
desktop and it's not just scrolling you
can sit there and type away it will do
clicks and options and it's just a
really nice pleasant way of just syncing
up multiple devices
so I think whatever you end up using for
tools i think it's worth considering how
fast you can actually get a turnaround
over what you're doing so the next thing
is launching like I kind of spared you
from it with that demo where I painfully
try and type in an IP address and then
fail miserably but out of interest of
all those people who test their multiple
devices who also then regularly tests
across multiple browsers on those
devices okay handful of people and it
you can kind of imagine wire right like
it's kind of a pain in the backside and
the main reason for that is you've got
to go across each of those devices
select each of the browsers do you want
to test against and then repeat for the
next version if you want to test across
that and then also you've got to enter
in the IP address and you could argue
well you put a bookmark or hopefully no
one touches the devices when I open up
that browser it's pointing to my machine
and no one ever touches it and it's all
fine and dandy you still got to touch
the browser anyway and it's kind of a
bottleneck for the number of devices you
test against so I came up with this
thing to scratch that itch for myself
and I'm hoping that other people will
find it kind of helpful as well and it's
it's called mini device lab because I
have no imagination whatsoever so all it
is is a small Cordova application with a
couple of plugins that I've written can
I position this in a sane way kind of
but not really okay so I sign in with
Google+ and what that's going to do is
basically generate an account for this
this device lab please work
I knew this was going to let me down
I've been sitting there going through it
there we go no apps no devices in the
lab so I hit sign in on both of these it
won't ask me to do anything because
Google+ sign-in has this nice thing
where you don't have to do it once
you've agreed once so once you've done
that you literally don't need this app
anymore so I'm going to fling it into
the abyss hit refresh on my desktop
that's definitely not good cool there we
go so now I've got two devices and I've
got a couple of browser so if I hit
launch on this damn you Nexus 10 see
what's going to be really bad as well as
the nexus 10 is going to kick in as soon
as I start doing other stuff there we go
so the idea with this is I enter in a
URL and it launches across the devices
in that device lab now the nice thing
with this if I go back to our lovely go
slabs demo and I want to launch it and
let's say Firefox damn you twitter i'm
presenting and you know it if i go and
select firefox to launch across those
devices it's not totally clear but the
tablet is launched firefox with the URL
and the nexus 4 has gone to the Play
Store because it's not pre-installed so
even though you haven't got the browsers
there it kind of simplifies it a little
bit to some extent and the idea with
this it was literally to get to this
point where I can it encourages you to
have multiple dices that you can
actually develop against and actually
support the browsers that are on those
devices at the moment it is one hundred
percent in alpha stages you kind of sore
from my praying to the gods that it
would work but it's all open source on
github you still have to sort out your
own App Engine instance and stuff but
I'm hoping to get to a point where I can
just release it on the Play Store and
I'll support and other stuff because it
is just a cord over application I just
need to be the plug-in bit and the main
thing with it as well is a lot of the
tools out there say enter in this IP
address and I kind of wanted to get to a
point we it will work with those tools I
don't get in the way so that's what I
was going to say on launch so then the
other thing is emulations with emulators
and all the other stuff and I kind of
expect most you might be say the thing
we all hang on you've talked about
devtools emulation now you're talking
about devices and now you're talking
about emulators as well why do I need
all these different options what the
hell are you talking about and they all
have pros and cons devices that the big
con of these is you have to buy them
nobody wants to spend money on these
kind of things at the same time you kind
of need them like you get close to what
the user is going to be experiencing at
the end of the day and arguably they can
be easier to work with compared to the
other stuff dev tools emulation it's
great for sanity checking what you're
going to end up giving to a user but the
problem is you're stealing from your
still in chrome on the desktop does it
you don't have feature parity with
chrome for android so if you imagined
back in the day when WebRTC may have
come to come for desktop and lock Chrome
for Android it will still look like
you've got WebRTC on a nexus 4 in
devtools emulation you install it on
device and obviously it will fail but it
is still awesome for the fact that
you're testing the UI emulators they're
incredibly useful when you need to test
a particular platform and essentially
these specific configurations the
biggest problem is sometimes it can be a
bit of a faff to sort out performance
doesn't necessarily match the device
either iOS is super fast and you might
find you have performance issues on the
device Android is kind of notoriously
bad out of the box just when you start
using it and the other thing is there is
no I should have said this no app stores
which means there's no evergreen
browsers you can get into those
emulators I think Firefox have public
builds veil
for their apks we have content shell
which you can actually get and it's
basically like Chrome for Android the
rendering but without any of the nice
creamy bits the link at the bottom is to
an article Paul Kinlan had put together
and basically it's a shell script it'll
look at the latest part of the source
tree with the latest build of content
shell and then install it to anything
that is connected to a TV at that time
so if you've got an emulator open or a
device connected install content show so
I'm not entirely sure how to pronounce
this so I'm going to say it's Intel
xhamter be a fish abut i'm going to call
it extreme ham this is essentially
something you can install in your
machine from intel and basically if you
use an intel-based android emulator as
well from the sdk tools it basically
allows the emulator to get access to the
cpu and run a bit faster than what you
would normally get the other one is any
of you guys heard of Jeannie motion
before that guy has and there's so
Jeannie motion is a company which is
basically building versions of I did
have it there we go so they basically
take builds of Android and I believe
they put it inside like a virtual box
style environment so it runs quite
smoothly
now you've still got that issue it
doesn't have the Play Store but it shows
up in a DB so if you've got the apks
again you can just install it on there
it's quite a nice option I think there
might be some stuff around the kinds of
processor that it's running as in
VirtualBox but it's quite speedy and if
you just need to support the Android
Browser like it's already there so it
might be a slightly nicer way to support
that so if you're pulling your hair out
and looking like pull loose so there are
cloud-based emulator options as well I'm
sure you guys have seen this browser
stack kind of focuses more on the
interactive playing around with of
emulators they've got a much wider range
of devices than I've seen anywhere else
in terms of like emulating different
viewport sizes and resolutions etc but
it does still kind of suffer with the de
novo green browsers source labs is
another one both of these have local
tunnelling support so you can just route
your local server to them interesting
thing with sauce labs is they have
interactive session support but they
kind of focus more towards the automated
testing so they have webdriver support
and the nice thing with that is if you
run through a script until it's say
enter in this text item click these
buttons scroll here it lets you record a
video of that entire session so you can
review it at the end and then the last
one that I was going to talk about was
device anywhere the nice thing with what
these guys are doing is basically you're
controlling real devices there and then
they've basically allows you to control
them remotely which means you
essentially get any actual wrong so that
come with these devices so many browsers
that come with them and if you're
finally you've got quirks are really
specific to one device this might be a
really nice way of finding out what
those are without actually needing to
buy the device the one and only
criticism and this is they are actually
real devices which mean people go into
settings and say hey I'm going to put a
password on this phone enjoy you can
there is like a help box on the side so
you can hopefully just get it fixed but
it takes a little while so if you were
kind of pushing something out the door
and then someone goes that can you
check this that kind of be a bit
disappointing at that point so you've
got all these emulators and it's all
super awesome and then you come to
debugging a problem so there is winery
it's kind of it's kind of one of those
things that you wish just didn't ever
exist but the same time you love it
because it's kind of a last resort you
can get it from NPM install it and just
add a script tag and it'll just start
basically giving you really basic
debugging so if you've got nothing else
give it a go for the Android webview
there's also this j/s hi bugger and it
does some really quite clever stuff that
essentially allows you to debug the
webview using chrome devtools so i have
my every useful touch example
application which i can show you there
and i drag that down and the little
android pops up that's literally all it
does but if I go into chrome inspect and
fumble about a bit
there we go you should see we get this
jazz come on you get this jay s high
bugger that comes up and about inspect
so this is just the everyday Android
webview but one of the really nice
things to this is you can go in as you
were before change various aspects of
the entire thing but what I I kind of
accidentally fumbled around and found
this but you can actually put break
points into the JavaScript so that point
I put a brake on changed state ending
touch so a minute left it off it just
starts going hey what do you want to do
but it comes with the whole set of
really nice features that winery simply
doesn't have so if you're kind of
getting to this point where Android with
you and winery and you just doesn't work
it's definitely worth checking ji bugger
and there's also a plug-in for called
over so you can literally add the
plug-in and you get all of that set up
the last thing I wanted to talk about in
terms of emulations is the notion of
basically throttling your network to see
what a user might be getting this video
is like an old version my website and
essentially one side has Wi-Fi the other
side has 2g connection guess which one
is which and the really nice thing with
this is it's easy to forget that one
where another network speed is going to
be a real big variable for your users
and what a particular like it's a notion
of if you're showing text and it's
actually appearing really fast but
you've basically waiting for a heavy
background image to load up you can just
apply like a dark background and
hopefully things will appear a bit
faster this is a nice way of just giving
you access to see that that's going to
have an effect same as if you actually
spend time smooshing down all your
resources you can actually kind of see
the benefit of it the link at the bottom
is format camels blog post on net
link conditioning which is OSX but
Charles proxy seems to be kind of the
cross-platform option for throttling
your network speed there we go so that
for me is kind of the whole suite of
things for mobile development find a
flow that works for you on desktop and
then gives you the extra tools that you
want for mobile I'd say consider having
a little look at device lab and having a
play with it because for me it was one
thing that really became apparent as
being an issue and then emulation just
try and get yourself set up with the
emulators that you know you're probably
going to want to use and just try and
treat it as kind of a part of your
workflow so that's all I was going to
see I've included some there were some
links to github link for the mini device
lab mobile on H of rocks there's also my
google i/o talk on modern workflow and
then addy Osmani has done another
awesome set of presentations on modern
what flow as well so that's what I
wanted to say thank you very much
excellent stuff so it's now another
break the breakout sessions that are
happening later they've been selected
based on on your votes if you want to
know where they're going to take place
you can go to bit ly / CD s breakouts
but they're also listed on the board
outsize you can just have a look there
some of them are going to be in here but
some of them are going to be elsewhere
so you can find out which ones you want
to take part in so Paul and Matt are
going to be upstairs doing Q&A during
the breaks if you have any any questions
to ask them they'll be up there and then
we're back at free 30 when the the
chrome and Android leads are going to be